hello everybody and welcome I am Andrew
Doris I'm a grad student here at the
Jackson Institute for Global Affairs as
well as the student organizer of today's
debate on alternative voting methods
sponsored by Yale effective altruism
thank you all for coming you are all
invited to ask questions at any time in
the chat box at the bottom of the screen
and at the end I will reappear to relay
as many of those questions as possible
to our panelists but for now it is my
privilege to introduce our esteemed
moderator Lisa DT rice is an independent
political strategist who's passionate
about democracy reform and political
innovation
she is on the board of the uh Board of
Directors for unite America which is a
non-partisan political movement working
to foster a representative and
functional government
she's also on the board of directors for
the National Coalition for cancer
survivorship and is an influential
advocate for multiple causes including
cancer policy reform women's leadership
and empowerment and political reform
in last year's election cycle Lisa
moderated a debate of six candidates
vying for the U.S House seat for the
District of Columbia so today's debate
should be a piece of cake by comparison
she holds a ba from Newcomb college and
is the president of the Newcomb Alumni
Association and also holds an SM degree
in management from the MIT Sloan School
Lisa thank you so much for being here
today
you're welcome Andrew hi and good
afternoon everyone
I'm I'm really happy to be here today
and we're going to talk about
um something that is actually pretty
exciting to me because I think that uh
if we can vote better we will have
um better turnout will attract more
people to voting and the more people to
vote the better the results that's my
personal opinion so um we won't talk
about my personal opinion anymore we'll
get into introducing Lee and Aaron Lee
druttman is a senior fellow in the
political reform program at new America
he is the author of breaking the
two-party Dune Loop the case for
multi-party Democracy in America and the
business of America is lobbying he's
winner of the 2016 American Political
Science association's Robert adal award
given for scholarship of the highest
quality on the subject of democracy
Lee is also co-host of the podcast
politics in question and writes for the
New York Times Vox and 538 among other
outlets he holds a PhD in political
science from the University of
California Berkeley in a ba from Brown
University
also we have Aaron Hamlin Aaron is the
executive director and co-founder of a
center for election science he's been
featured as an electoral systems expert
on MSNBC NPR Free Speech TV
inside philanthropy
80 000 hours Popular Mechanics and has
given talks around the country on voting
methods he's written for Deadspin USA
Today magazine independent voter Network
and others additionally Aaron is a
licensed attorney with two additional
graduate degrees in the social sciences
thank you both for being here today and
we will kick it off with Lee and explain
a little bit about ranked Choice voting
and we've got a video and then we'll
follow with Aaron who's got another
video about approval voting and I will
ask Lee to kick it off
great well thank you for that
introduction and I'm really thrilled to
be uh having this conversation today I
think it's a really important
conversation because I think uh there's
a tremendous frustration with our
current voting system I think what we
all uh participating in this debate
agree that the single winner plurality
system has some really perverse effects
it limits Choice uh it makes it uh hard
for people to express their sincere
preferences and it's driving incredible
divisiveness in our politics uh so you
know I'm excited to have this
conversation because I think there's a
bunch of single winner elections in our
political system that are just
inherently going to be single winner of
obviously president but also Governors
races Senators races Mayors races and
and for these single winner seats we
ought to to think about what the the
better system is so I think the best way
to explain voting systems is with fun
cartoon videos as we can all agree on so
let's run the fun cartoon video for
ranked Choice voting if we can
so what is ranked Choice coding
in most parts of the United States
voters select a single candidate for
each position on their ballot and the
candidate with the most votes wins this
is known as single Choice winner take
all which can sometimes result in the
election of a candidate who earned only
a small percentage of the vote even when
the majority of Voters supported other
candidates
but that's not the only way of electing
our leaders ranked Choice voting is
another voting method which allows
voters to rank their candidates in order
of preference
in a ranked Choice voting election a
candidate needs to earn more than half
of the votes to win
all first choices are counted and if a
candidate has a majority then they win
just like any other election
if not the candidate with the fewest
votes is eliminated and voters who
picked that candidate as number one will
have their votes count for their next
choice this process continues until a
candidate earns a majority and is
declared the winner
let's look at an example
here you select orange as your first
choice candidate yellow as your second
Pink as your third and green as your
final choice
the first choices are counted
yellow earned 35 orange 21 pink earned
28 and green earned 16 of the vote
because nobody won more than 50 percent
the candidate with the fewest votes is
eliminated and voters who picked him as
their first choice have their balance
count for their second choice
this continues until a candidate
receives more than half of the votes or
50 plus one
so what are some of the benefits of
ranked Choice voting ranked Choice
voting provides more choices allowing
more than two candidates to compete
without fear of splitting the vote among
like-minded individuals
sometimes voters feel pressured to vote
for the lesser of two evils ranked
Choice voting allows people to vote for
their favorite candidate not just
against the candidates they dislike
with ranked Choice voting we see more
positive campaigns and less negative
advertising
candidates are encouraged to reach out
to as many voters as possible including
those supporting their opponents they
can build a winning Coalition with
like-minded candidates to earn voters
second and third choices
it's time to fix our democracy and make
our elections work better for everybody
we can do that with ranked Choice voting
visit
www.fairvote.org to find out how you can
get involved
all right well thank you cartoon
explainer
um so I want to just talk briefly about
why I like ranked Choice voting in
addition to uh the reasons that were
mentioned in that fun little video it
encourages you know more
positive campaigning more Coalition
building more compromise but one of the
other things that I like about ranked
Choice voting is is that we know that it
works because it's been used for over a
hundred years in Australia for 100 years
in Ireland many other countries around
the world uh use it it we know that it
works because it's all those countries
are are been successful thriving
democracies Australia has a century of
moderate politics uh we know that it's
widely recommended by election experts
who uh have have studied all of these
voting systems and it's particularly
recommended in uh divided and
pluralistic Societies in which Coalition
bill building is uh especially important
and that's because we know from again
from 100 Years of of experience that it
encourages compromise and Coalition
building in politics and you know I
think most importantly and this is going
to be I think a point of contention in
this debate is that I think it makes the
most realistic assumptions about how
voters campaigns and parties will behave
uh it assumes that there is going to be
a level of strategic voting and what
makes rank Choice voting work well is
that it's really a hard system to game
it encourages people to vote their
sincere preferences because there's no
real uh benefit in not doing so uh and
you know I I think that is incredibly
important uh so I think it it
aligns the incentives properly it has
you know again and I think this is
really important you know we have lots
and lots of evidence that it works this
is not doesn't have to be a theoretical
debate we we can go to to the record and
you know I think you know again it makes
uh realistic and reasonable assumptions
about how people are going to behave
both voters and candidates in very high
stakes elections so with that I will
turn it over uh to Aaron so you can hear
about why he likes approval voting
foreign
it's a pleasure being here
so when we're talking about approval
voting uh I think this explanation is
going to be uh pretty simple approval
voting is simply allowing you to select
as many candidates as you approve of as
many as you effectively are comfortable
with serving in office and the candidate
with the most approvals or votes wins
that's it it's not a complicated system
uh but uh just to do service here uh we
also have an explainer video so feel
free to run the explainer video
what is approval voting simply put it's
a better way to run an election let's
take a trip to Plantsville it's election
time and mayor blueberry is campaigning
hard for a second term in office she won
the last election with 65 percent
against her opponent Mr squash and she
still enjoys strong support
once again Mr squash is quick to
challenge Miss blueberry but this time
they're joined by a third Challenger Mr
Peach who shares similar views with
mayor blueberry
Mr Peach sweet talks almost half of
blueberries supporters into switching
their vote to him while Mr squash holds
the same 35 percent he had last time the
votes are counted and what's this Mr
squash win blueberry and Peach have
split the fruit vote how did this happen
peaches supporters also like blueberry
but couldn't say so on their ballots a
simple solution is to change the ballot
from vote from one to vote for one or
more allowing everyone to State all the
candidates they support this is called
approval voting
with approval voting the election would
have gone quite differently
teaches supporters no longer fear that a
vote for peach will help elect squash
instead they show their sincere support
for peach and also blueberry they want
to prevent Mr squash from winning and
they do an approval voting accurately
reflects Peach's support mayor blueberry
wins the election democracy is restored
approval voting is more than just a
smart idea in plant spill it's a smart
idea anywhere you vote
approval voting is used by organizations
across the globe and for good reason
Democratic because the candidate with
the most support wins it removes the
spoiler effect
even losing candidates get an accurate
reflection of support
and voting your favorite never hurts you
start the conversation on approval
voting and share this video then join
the center for election science at
electrology.org
better voting starts with you foreign
thank you
um and approval voting really is the
simple solution that we need to upgrade
our democracy
um and we don't need establishment
Gatekeepers to tell us what we can and
can't do uh our democracy and well-being
is just too important to have to wait
for permission indeed in Fargo and St
Louis The Establishment there was not
very excited about approval voting and
that's because they knew it was going to
challenge their power and so when we
worked with key stakeholders within that
community
we worked with them to help bring them
that power back and and interestingly
the the two places where we've uh worked
so far Fargo and St Louis I think on the
surface it appears like these are really
different places but they were looking
at really Three core components of a
voting method and these are components
that we're going to keep coming back to
uh one is you want a voting method that
is
robust to vote spinning it's able to
show a clear uh mandate when one is
present and being able to elect a
consensus candidate second is being able
to have an idea of how much support
candidates actually have you want to
make sure that voices are heard and if
you're not able to show the support of
all the candidates well you're missing
out on all these different voices
and thirdly you want a voting method
that is uh not unnecessarily expensive
and not overly complicated
with the vote spinning and mandate
component uh you had uh candidates
winning with just a mere fraction of the
boat in both Fargo and St Louis since
approval voting has been implemented
we've seen candidates win uh be winning
with uh or or leading with uh wall over
uh 50 support
um and it's not to say that that will
always happen again no voting method can
guarantee a majority so like when we see
ranked Choice voting Advocates talk
about always getting a majority that's
really an artificial majority uh uh if
you throw away all the Cannons but two
of course you're going to get a majority
any voting method can do that and we're
going to talk again and again about
being able to share with the reflection
of support for candidates we're going to
talk about polling and how uh that's
played out in terms of approval voting
showing the accurate reflection and
support for candidates and both St Louis
and and Fargo they were told that there
were only a choice before was Frank
Trace building and so they couldn't
afford new voting machines and so
approval voting was really their only
way forward so we need an approach that
gives winners the necessary uh support
to be able to make bold decisions we
need an approach to encourages new ideas
to flourish and we need an approach that
is practical so overall we need approval
voting
thanks Aaron
so for the next 25 to 30 minutes we're
going to go through some questions and
um each each person will have
two to three minutes
total
two minutes to answer save a minute for
rebuttal and we'll start uh with Lee why
is your method preferable to the other
great uh thank you
um you know I I think I mean the the
easiest uh way to think about ranked
Choice voting
um uh verse is approval voting is to to
think about
um uh fact that one voting system has
you know 100 Years of support uh we know
the evidence is out there franchise
voting Works uh whereas approval voting
it's not a new voting system in fact
it's a voting system that is
older than orang Choice voting so I
think one question and I'll be curious
for uh Aaron's answer to this is why why
is it that although approval voting has
been around for a long time it's never
uh really caught on and I mean I think
the history shows that there have been
various moments in which some
organizations that have been have used
it and then they've they've discarded it
because it just leads to Bullet voting
there have been some other systems that
are similar to it that have been uh
discarded
um and you know I just think for
elections uh it just doesn't uh make a
lot of sense where as we know that
Rancho's voting makes sense because we
know it works because it thinks about
how voters and candidates actually
campaign and vote now I I do think that
that I I want to be entirely dismissive
of approval voting because I think that
there are cases in which a system of
approval voting makes sense and I think
these are systems where you know or
decisions where the stakes are low first
example if you filled out one of those
doodle polls where you're trying to
figure out when a good time to meet is
well that's approval voting and that's
the value of approval voting and it
works because under those conditions
you know most people don't have really
strong preferences there are equivocal
whether it's you know we meet it Tuesday
at four or Wednesday at 11. and you know
everybody's trying to find a time that
they can all meet together so
everybody's sincere they're not
strategic it's a pretty low stage thing
but you know if the stakes were a little
higher like you know say it wasn't just
for one meeting but a weekly staff
meeting well maybe I'd think differently
about about voting because you know
something about me is that I I like to
to work in the morning because that's my
most productive time I'd rather have
meetings in the afternoon I'm more
productive earlier in the week I'd
rather have meetings Friday so like you
know I'd say like Friday at three would
be my best time for a meeting uh and you
know that you know might not be a time
that's good for for other people but
like the question is how can we find the
time that's you know maybe you know most
most optimal for all people assuming
that we have preferences and I think
that that's the fundamental problem of
of approval voting is that it assumes
that people are equivocal and they don't
see any difference between a bunch of
different candidates and in the real the
reality is that the when it comes to
high-stakes selections which are you
know elections for mayor Senator
Governor as we sort of keep single
winter elections people have preferences
there are campaigns so you know I I
think uh you know curious you know why
folks who support approval voting think
that the election should follow the same
logic as as finding a meeting time on on
Doodle and what are all the the people
who recommend ranked Choice voting and
have recommended around the world and
all the countries and cities that have
chosen ranked Choice voting uh compared
to just a very few have chosen approval
voting what are they all missing uh you
know why so
I think those are those are some
important questions that I hope we can
get to here
Aaron why is your method preferable to
the other and do you want me to include
my rebuttal uh in my response as well
absolutely however you can go for it
so I'll use the the three minutes then
yeah okay
um so
in terms of why approval voting is
better than ranked choice I think we
again go back to those three issues uh
being able to elect a strong winner and
and again like when we're talking about
a winner one thing to keep in mind is
that nine out of ten times approval
voting and right choice voting are going
to select the same winner
um I think that's something that's not
really uh talked about a lot uh and
we've seen this play out through poem
that we've done in presidential
elections uh Democratic primary and in
other elections uh what really comes to
is uh where the the focus is in terms of
where the methods diverge
um and so we see one example here of
that uh potential Divergence we don't
know how approval voting necessarily
would have played out but we see an
example of where uh right Trace voting
has failed and I think the clear example
there that no one wants to talk about is
Burlington Vermont and that's an example
where
uh the person who was able to beat
everyone else Head to Head uh that
candidate lost because of vote spinning
within ranked Trace voting it uh there
was a vote spitting with First Choice
preferences and that candidate was
knocked out and lost uh and you also
hear a lot of claims that ranked Choice
voting lets you always rank your
favorites first well uh not the case uh
in Burlington Vermont conservatives uh
they were told the same thing they were
told that they could rank their
favorites first what happened as a
consequence uh there can they caused a
worse outcome they had the progressive
candidate the polar opposite of what
they would want when as a result so it
was a worse result for them and it was a
worse result for the electorate and
that's because that's even in the case
of of Voters voting honestly they're
getting a worse outcome when they're
voting honestly
um and another key example of being able
to see when uh a voting method uh is
performing well it's when it's actually
able to capture the support of what
people want including with candidates
who don't win
we see time and again approval voting
does an excellent job capturing the
support of all the candidates including
third parties and independents we saw
this in the Democratic primary for
instance I think Yang is a great example
here under both priority voting and
ranked Choice voting uh Yang got under
10 whereas under approval voting uh he
got roughly 30 percent this is a case
where a candidate with new ideas needs
to be heard when people support them and
he's getting ignored had he used
approval voting he would have gotten the
support that he deserves and we did a
control measure we asked people how they
honestly felt there
um and uh we saw that line up uh so it
wasn't just a fluke and we're just
seeing uh time and again of uh these
candidates getting ignored uh this idea
of momentum I think is one that doesn't
make much sense uh so uh sure uh break
Trace voting has been around a while but
like it's also been repealed it's been
repealed in Burlington for a month Ann
Arbor Michigan uh Carey North Carolina
Aspen Colorado Pierce County Washington
Sunnyvale California it's failed by over
16 in a number of initiatives
um and in Alaska like it passed recently
but it failed the first time uh
Massachusetts it failed by over uh 10
and we can't just celebrate merely
because a voting method gets a result
any voting method can get a result what
we want is a consistent result that
gives us good winners and a reflection
of support for all the candidates and
approval voting is what does that
okay thank you
um our next question is about
um resistance to strategic voting but
what I wanted to do very quickly because
everyone might not be the voting Geeks
that we are I'll I'll say what strategic
voting is strategic voting it's
sometimes referred to as tactical voting
it's when a voter casts their ballot for
a candidate that is not their first
choice in order to prevent someone else
from winning
um and so we'll proceed into the next
question which is which method is more
resistant to strategic voting and why
Lisa do you want to give Lee a chance
for his repo as well
um you know
you know you know I think critics of
brain Choice voting often bring up the
case of of Burlington Vermont
um which was you know one election in
which ranked Choice voting did yield a
weird result
um you know and no system is perfect I
mean I think I think we have to be
honest about that up front that that
every uh system under certain conditions
can yield an unexpected result that you
know if there were a perfect voting
system we'd all be using that voting
system uh but you know that that's a you
know a fundamental fallacy of selecting
on your dependent variable which is
picking the one outcome that supports
your uh argument and cherry picking uh
and ignoring the the many number of
Elections that have been held under
ranked Choice voting that have worked
just fine and again Australia has
happily used this system for a hundred
years Ireland is happily used this
system for 100 years it's been used in
many elections in in the U.S and in uh
St Paul Minneapolis Oakland uh San
Francisco it's now being used in New
York in the primary it's in Maine it's
in Alaska and yes it's not going to win
every ballot initiative because you know
a lot of people haven't heard of it and
they don't understand it yet uh but you
know the more people understand it the
more people are enthusiastic about that
and you know I know that having watched
the progress of ranked Choice voting
over the last few years that once people
get it they like it
okay
are we ready to move into the next
question
Aaron do you wanna
answer the next question should I start
restate it
sure maybe for the audience yeah which
method is more resistant to strategic
voting and why
so here when we're talking about
strategic voting the idea of someone uh
voting in the way that uh benefits them
overall I think perhaps more important
here is uh how does someone optimizing
their own vote voting the way that they
feel is uh necessary how does that play
into the outcome because if it doesn't
give you uh if the voting method is
robust to to strategic voting and still
gives you a strong outcome then I don't
think there's a big worry there
so with approval voting I think a lot of
the times
um uh opponents look at this and say
like well uh people are just going to
vote for one candidate and that's going
to be it
well
I don't think that's a big deal in some
cases it's going to make sense foreign
an individual voter to vote for one
candidate if that makes sense for them
that makes sense for them you can still
have even if say three quarters of
people are choosing only one candidate
and then some elections that may make
sense uh for uh for most voters uh
but even with that remainder
uh that's enough to cover the margin of
Victory to change the winner if indeed a
different winner uh uh should be
necessary it also makes it so that the
uh other candidates are able to get
their reflection support uh heard so
overall I'm not uh concerned with this
as long as you are getting strong
winners uh that's the main concern and
as long as other candidates are getting
the accurate reflection support
um then I think the voting method is
doing its job I would be more concerned
again with the voting method that when
people are voting honestly uh that they
get a worse outcome uh and again like
taking a brilliant and and we have to
pick on things like Burlington because
again uh nine out of ten times these
voting methods are going to get the same
result so we have to kind of focus on
that that 10
and as Rick Trace voting is implemented
in more places we're going to see more
of Burlington's
um but really we want to focus on uh
voting method that gets a good outcome
and does its job on being able to
capture can support and those are areas
where approval voting hands down does
better
you know I'm I just wanna
flag something here because I I'm a
little confused I'm hearing terms like
good outcome and I haven't heard those
defined yet I'm hearing terms like
strong candidate and I haven't heard
those defined yet so I hope Aaron will
define those uh in in his uh rebuttal
here
um you know I I
so I mean Aaron is telling us that nine
times out of ten uh ranked Choice voting
and approval voting will uh get the same
result and I I don't know what that's
based on uh because you know that they
haven't been run in the same elections
it might be based on hypothetical
polling or or modeling but but that's
not the real world uh you know the the
the argument that I'm hearing right now
is that it's really folk we're really
focusing on the voter and the voter
satisfaction and the voters are
important but they're also part of a
broader political system right now we
have a very broken and destructive
political system uh that is highly
polarized highly binary highly divisive
and so you know I think we ought to
think about which political system is
going to help solve those problems but
this this question is on the sincere
versus strategic voting and you know I
I'm actually not sure that I mean this
is all hypothetical because we don't we
don't know because you know we just
don't have a lot of experience with
approval voting
um that we're gonna that that the the
results would be the same but I just
wanna
because we need hypothetical examples
you know I just want to take what I
think might be a realistic hypothetical
example which is to say that
uh Aaron Lisa and I are all running for
Senator uh and I'm on the left and
Aaron's on the right and Lisa's in the
middle and she's got to be the moderate
right because she's the moderator
um don't don't all laugh at once
um okay so uh you know and let's say
this audience is like the American
electorate you know 40 left 20 Center 40
right and you know probably if everybody
were voting sincerely Lisa should be the
winner but here's the problem is that I
would know that so I got to tell my
supporters don't vote for Lisa uh
because I think I can beat Aaron head to
head if you all turn out and nobody
votes for Lisa because she would get you
know her 20 plus my 40 meant she's gonna
beat me uh and Aaron's strategy is the
same so he's going to tell us supporters
not to vote for Lisa too because he
knows this and then I know this so you
know I know that definitely his
supporters so you can you can you can
game this out and what we wind up is
that we've devolved back into to
standard plurality zero-sum voting so
and you know and this is the experience
of approval voting is that often just
devolves back into to Bullet voting with
the same demonization and you know
frankly I think Lisa's pretty smart and
and she might realize what she's what
was going to happen to her and she's not
going to even run under this scenario
now RCV is going to be different because
you know it's possible that Lisa uh you
know will still get the 20 first first
preference choices but now she's a lot
more important because Aaron and I both
are going to really want her second
choices and we have no incentive to
demonize her because we already have our
40 what we want is to move towards uh
the middle and get her supporters and
build coalitions and this is why RCV is
Superior in my mind is because it
encourages even candidates you know on
the edges to work towards building a
broader Coalition in approval voting the
goal of candidates is to tell all their
supporters or dominant candidates
tellers their supporters to Bullet vote
in Rancho's voting
I'm trying to build a broader Coalition
so yeah I think when we think about
these systems we have to think voting
systems we have to think about them as a
broader part of the political systems we
have to think about how campaigns are
going to operate we have to think how
candidates are going to operate and we
have to think how voters are going to be
responsive to that and the dominant
strategy in approval voting is just to
Bullet vote and if Aaron's fine with
that then I don't know why we're even
why we even bother to change to approval
voting because then we might as well
just stick with Pro plurality voting and
and save us the hassle
Aaron
yeah so uh lee asked well what makes a
good winner I think that's uh that's a
fair question
um so uh a good winner is one that Max
has the maximum support of the
electorate over any other candidate uh
and when we do polling uh we ask people
as well there we ask their honest
opinion along with how they would vote
under different election scenarios and
approval voting much more than ranked
Choice voting It lines up with people's
honest opinion we asked people that in
St Louis as well their approval voting
uh support uh lined up with their honest
assessment uh so uh and that was even
and and also people voted for 1.6 uh
candidates uh uh per ballot in St Louis
uh so even there like we're hardly
seeing bullet voting being uh rampant
but if it was like maybe it makes sense
for those voters as well what's
important is that we get good winners
and we can measure good winners uh while
we're doing this polling
um and so that's what I would say uh so
if if you're getting good results
um really that's really all that matters
okay
are we ready to move on to the next
question
and we are we're a little squeezed on
our time so I'm going to ask a question
and ask that each of you um watch your
time on answer and rebuttal the next
question which method produces more
moderate winners and is this always good
B you want to kick off
um sure yeah and you know again uh you
know I keep coming back to this but I
think this is an incredibly important
point that with ranked Choice voting we
don't have to rely on hypothetical polls
that are divorced from the Rough and
Tumble of actual campaigns we can
actually look at the record and you know
we can look at 100 Years of moderate
Australian politics we can look at 100
Years of relatively moderate Irish
politics and we you know we don't know
from approval voting
um because there's just no history there
we can do polls all we want but polls
are you know polls are polls are
actually uh Aaron was talking about a
good way of we want to know what
candidate support actually is well
actually polling is a good way to to
know that we don't you know that so we
have a way to do that
um you know just just you don't want to
talk about the the St Louis election
because that is the the case that we
have most recently of of
approval voting and I want to know that
that was a a two candidate election not
not a single winner candidate election
so actually one point even though voters
were selecting two candidates they
actually undervoted uh at 1.6 and and
actually turnout went down in St Louis
so there was just 22 turnout in this
election which was actually down 11 000
votes from uh four years ago uh and you
know so uh I think with RCV you actually
uh get more people using those rankings
and so you're more likely to figure out
what the the moderate winner is and I
think you know again I'm having this I'm
finding it hard to understand what what
Aaron really says about a a good outcome
is who who has maximal support uh among
the elector I think what he's trying to
get at is you know who would be the the
Condor say winner which is you know the
idea who would who would win the most
head-to-head uh
match-ups you know which you know it is
a sort of gold standard for how you
measure electoral systems but it's also
impossible to achieve unless everybody
ranks every candidate which is just not
uh gonna happen so
uh you know I I just I'm just perplexed
there I think uh you know I mean there's
a fundamental problem of course in
getting moderate winners uh which is
that there's you know tremendous
polarization in our society and you know
if the electorate is divided it's going
to be really hard to to find a moderate
winner uh and you know frankly this is a
fundamental problem with single winner
election systems and and I hope we'll
debate at a later point the value of
multi-winner proportional electoral
systems which are really important for
generating more moderate uh winners but
I think we have to work from the reality
of where we are and so the question is
not necessarily which is the system
that's going to most elect the most
moderate so though I think boring Choice
voting would do that but more
importantly which is the system that's
going to incentivize the most moderation
given that we have an electorate that is
deeply polarized and again for reasons
that I I hope are are clear I think that
system is ranked Choice voting because
it encourages candidates to build the
broadest coalition to ensure that they
have majority support whereas in
approval voting there is a strategic
decision of Voters and campaigns to try
to get their supporters to Bullet vote
which again creates the same device of
zero-sum dissatisfaction problems of
plurality voting
thanks Aaron
sure
um so when I said that a a good winner
is one that maximizes uh the support
from the electorate that's what I meant
uh conversation winner is another way of
doing it but we need to talk about voter
satisfaction and so when I said that
that's what I meant
um and when we're talking about uh
getting moderate winners really like
we're talking about getting the
candidate uh who uh maximizes us has the
most support from the electorate
themselves and moderate is going to vary
from place to place so really when it
comes down to it that's what we want we
want a strong consensus winner when
we're talking about who we want to win
uh so uh lee mentioned that St Louis was
a two-person election uh so this here we
have approval voting being used uh we
can choose as many candidates as you
want and then it goes to a runoff in St
Louis uh but I uh thought there might be
some naysayers ahead of time uh so
fortunately when uh when we were doing
our research design in St Louis we also
asked them how they would vote if there
was no runoff would they have voted
differently and indeed some people would
have voted differently uh the votes per
ballot would have dropped uh slightly
from 1.6 to about 1.5 But ultimately we
have the same winner same winner order
and roughly the same support among all
the candidates as well and it's
important to uh do these polls alongside
real elections because otherwise you run
into uh Fantastical hypotheticals that
uh that folks dream up uh and so when we
look at a particular election what we do
is we ask people okay well here's an
option using a particular voting method
how would you have voted if this was the
voting method and then we also asked
them what their honest assessment is of
these candidates and we ask them that in
different ways we asked them uh by using
a likert type scale we asked them by
ranking their their honest rankings and
they ask them who they honestly approve
of uh and when we looked at that
compared to the approval voting data
through the election uh it worked out
well like those lined up
and I one of there are a number of
reasons why ranked three Zodi May
struggle here uh one is that it's not
very good data to begin with
um when you're looking at rankings you
don't know where the threshold is for
where someone approves a candidate and
where they don't uh so you're
fundamentally not having information to
begin with and also the method is so
complicated that many cities truncate
the amount of information that you can
provide so if you don't get the
information to begin with of course
you're going to have trouble getting a
good result so even when a voting method
like for interest voting appears to be
getting good results well like we don't
always know because like there's a lack
of information and uh when you have more
candidates which by the way uh cities on
average have eight mayoral candidates uh
good luck doing that with the ranked
choice but the voting election when
people get tired of breaking through
those uh through those candidates it's
much easier to do that with approval
voting even when you have a long
candidate list and that's how you get
these better results
okay
um Lee did you have a rebuttal or are we
ready I I mean I you know I I think
we're we're you know arguing uh angels
on a on a on a pin with this you know
what what counts as a as a better result
uh I mean
approval voting assumes I mean we're
talking about voter preference and
measuring that uh yeah I think approval
voting assumes that you either like a
candidate or you don't like a candidate
but you know writing Choice voting data
is is I think actually quite more
informative because you are much more
likely people you know
mostly use their ranking so they people
are much more likely to vote for
multiple candidates under ranked systems
and you actually have an incredible uh
a trove of data to see you know who who
were first preferences who were second
preferences who were third preferences
and you can you can vote for uh more
candidates down the ballot without
harming your favorite if your favorite
is is a leading candidate and that
actually uh I think generates you know a
better sense of of who uh of who voters
prefer uh and and Broad support you know
but you know again I think you know and
the the fundamental thing that's
happening in this debate
um that I'm finding a little frustrating
is you know it seems like Aaron is
trying to to abstract the voting system
outside of the politics and kind of talk
about a pure Condor say winner and you
know I I think it is important to think
about the the elections as part of a
political process so it's part of how
people campaign it's part of how people
govern uh and you know
and it's part of how voters engage and
you know a
franchise voting is a way for voters to
be very expressive and a way for
candidates to reach out to a lot of
different candidates and you you survey
voters in cities that have used
franchise voting and you know 90 91 92
percent of people say they were
satisfied they say it was easy you know
it's a it's a myth that people find it
hard there's a few people who find it
hard the first time they do it but you
know it's really not that hard to rank
we rank all the time what are your 10
favorite movies what are your 10
favorite books you know what are your 10
favorite beers
so you know I'm just a little perplexed
here
all right so I tell you what we're going
to do we're going to table the
discussion for the moment
um on which system is better and let's
go to the next topic suppose you've
convinced the audience that your method
is best
what are the biggest obstacles to
reforming the existing system
how can they be overcome
and what can our audience do to help
Lee do you want to start and you'll get
three minutes to respond yeah well you
know I I think we're at uh a real
inflection point in our democracy in
that we're having a very broad democracy
reform conversation and some of that is
around the immediate challenges of uh
voter suppression uh and you know
Georgia just passed a very restrictive
voter ID law uh and the Democrats
response uh for the people act hr1 and
and you know we're really thinking about
what it means to have a fair democracy
and I think this is a decades-long a
decade-long conversation at least uh and
so I I think it's important to to think
about this in in a broader context that
this is this is not just you know about
ranked Choice voting or approval voting
it's about what is going to make for a
fair representative just Equitable
democracy particularly in this moment in
which we are transitioning as a Society
to being a multi-ethnic democracy and
and really you know dealing with some of
these very nasty and ugly uh legacies of
of earlier uh regressive Jim Crow errors
in our politics
um you know so I
I want to make sure that we are having
these conversations as part of that
bigger conversation and I think it's
important in this moment to you know
have a have a broad conversation about
alternative voting systems uh which
which we are doing now and I think one
of the challenges is that you know we
have to understand some of the ways in
which our voting system itself is
contributing to our political problems
as you mentioned the author of the book
breaking the two-party Doom Loop the
case for multi-party Democracy in
America in which I argue that it is in
fact our two-party system that is
fostering uh an incredible divisiveness
and at a multi-party system I think
would work much better because it breaks
the binary nature of our political
conflict which is exacerbating so many
of these US versus them uh
problems and also you know is allowing a
a political minority to have outsized
power because it's well placed in our
system and you know here I think we also
ought to be thinking about proportional
representation I I mean I think there
are real we're having this debate about
single winner systems I think there are
real limits to single winner elections
although there are you know certainly
certain electoral offices that require
single winners so you know I think we
all also have to think about the the
equity aspects of this
um and in this case I think particularly
proportional ranked Choice voting is a
very good system for a diverse society
and again you know I go back to what
election experts uh talk about is that
you know if you if you have a divided
pluralistic society you want a
proportional system uh and probably a
ranked Choice voting system too in order
to build cross-coalitional support uh
yeah so I think you know I
it's it's important to get engaged in
these conversations I think the biggest
obstacle you know it is you know a lack
of imagination a sense that just because
we have the the status quo that that
that's just the only possibility that
there is and you know this is a moment
in which I'm thrilled that we're having
these debates because I think it's a
real moment to look at what's gone wrong
with our political system which is you
know clearly declining uh and you don't
have to ask me you can look at Freedom
House or any International rating now
everybody's looking at the US and saying
what what's going wrong so you know we
have to we have to expand our
imagination I think is the biggest
obstacle that's the biggest obstacle
okay Aaron how about you yeah I guess I
would ask first that we don't complete
uh ranked Choice voting or instant
runoff voting and single transferable
vote there's a very different systems uh
so uh uh here we're talking about uh
ranked Trace voting uh a winner versus
approval voting and
when we're looking at this I think there
are two obstacles really in terms of
like uh and these are in terms of like
arguments uh that are push against
approval voting and here we hear uh
issues about momentum and expression but
first like we need to recognize that we
have more options than ranked Choice
voting this is not the only option
approval voting is way easier uh and uh
it's free to implement uh so I don't uh
so we need to be able to keep this in
mind as an option in terms of of
momentum well uh the RCV folks
collectively have gotten over a million
100 million dollars over the last uh
couple decades you give any kind of
intervention that kind of funding and
timeline I'd hope I'd hope that they
make some kind of progress but the
question is
um given all that funding and timeline
uh why aren't they further than they are
you look at approval voting as an
organization we've been around with
funding for three years and within those
three years we've helped over 400 000
people uh get approval voting uh to help
give them a voice in their democracy
so uh sure like uh RCB is further along
but like look at the Head Start that I
got uh so I wouldn't really call that
momentum particularly when you're
looking at recent failures like
Massachusetts were lost by uh 10 points
um uh that's that doesn't look like
momentum to me and as far as
expressivity
we uh which which Lee had brought up uh
earlier this is also
um uh an obstacle that we see with
people looking at Frank Choice voting
versus approval voting uh but if uh if
you're filling out your ballot and
you're looking at the results and you
don't see your voice reflected in the
results something is wrong you look at
and and we're I see a lot of third party
parties being told that ranked Choice
voting is the solution for them it gives
them their voice you look at Maine in
Maine uh which was able to use ranked
tourist sorting for presidential
elections neither third party got over
two percent uh if third if Bank Trace
voting is supposed to help third parties
where is it happening you're looking at
federal Offices there they're not
getting over five percent uh whereas
when we look at approval voting time and
again like we look at the 2016 election
uh doing polling there uh uh Joe Stein
went from one person to nine percent uh
Gary Johnson went from uh three percent
to 21 uh you're not seeing any of those
games with ranked Choice building so
particularly if you want to see your
voice reflected regardless of what you
put on your ballot you need to use
approval voting that's what's going to
give you your voice
thank you
um it's time for us to
for each of you to give your closing
statements you each have three minutes
do you want to give Lee his rebuttal
um that that question we just put on the
table each of you got your three minutes
[Applause]
for that one all right
my rebuttal into the closing statement
all right well you're up all right so
yeah
uh you know I found it you know I I
didn't know that
um 100 million has been spent uh
sporting ranked Choice voting efforts uh
that's that's new to me but you know I
it suggests to me that the funders who
are looking at voting alternatives are
seeing something in ranked Choice voting
I mean these are folks who are very
careful with their money uh and do from
my experience do run all the traps and
try to figure out what uh things are are
effective and whatnot and the fact that
100 million dollars has already been
committed to ranked Choice voting
suggests that a lot of people have
independently come to the idea that
range was Voting it is uh a good system
of voting uh and again you know it's not
like approval voting has been around for
a long time franchise voting has been
around for a long time
um you know so this you know seems to me
something notable uh you know I mean a
franchise voting is not going to win
every campaign uh neither is approval
voting uh you know the women's suffrage
movement didn't win every uh campaign
you know when it started out either uh
you know the the I do want to address
the idea the question of which is
simpler uh because that was a question
that we were going to discuss before and
you know I think that you know the our
argument that that I hear from from
Aaron is that you know approval voting
is easy and and cheap to do and you know
so when I hear that you know it makes me
think well okay if it's easy and cheap
why hasn't anybody done it before in
fact people have there have been various
uses of approval voting and there are a
number of organizations that have
adopted it and almost in very terribly
it devolves into bullet voting and they
say this doesn't really work uh yeah and
look all voting systems have trade-offs
and there's complexities and you know in
some ways the you know if you want to if
you want a super simple voting system
you can use plurality voting uh you know
but the approval voting hides its
complexity uh because the complexity is
all in the Strategic calculations of
whether or not people should approve of
of multiple candidates now Rancho is
voting yeah it's a little bit more
complicated up front but it's a very
difficult system to game in and it
really encourages people to sincerely uh
you know vote now I I I hear Aaron
saying oh well we know that approval
works better because we've run polls
um you know this is a challenge for
approval voting is that all all approval
voting has are these polls because
there's just not a lot of real world
examples and again you know I I just you
know as somebody as a political as a
trained political scientist with a PhD
in political science author of several
books somebody who really takes research
and empirical analysis seriously you
know there are lots and lots of studies
of franchise voting with real data both
in the U.S and around the world so you
can look at a stack of research and you
can make your own conclusions with
approval voting you know it's it's
largely mathematical Theory abstracted
from reality now we have a few cities
that have again using it for for two
winter elections not single winner
elections uh and
you know it's it's it's all theoretical
uh I I think the theory relies on a
bunch of unrealistic assumptions about
how politics actually works I think the
folks who put a hundred million dollars
into uh ranked Choice voting would
probably agree again you know these are
folks who don't spend their their money
willy-nilly uh so you know I
I think you know with Rancho's voting we
don't have to guess uh we know it works
and we know that people are happy with
it and we know it encourages more
positive compromise oriented campaigning
we can look around the world we can look
in the U.S and to me that's a very
compelling case I've looked at the
research I you know I've I've looked at
it deeply uh you know and and so of
others I mean there are if you don't
believe me you know you know Barack
Obama Support over any choice voting
Elizabeth Warren supporter of of ranked
Choice voting uh you know there are a
lot of a lot of folks in Congress who
who support it uh I have not heard any
support uh at that level for approval
voting
okay Aaron
so uh lee mentioned the the funders and
so I would uh I would really ask the the
funders to uh
think about where they're putting their
Investments uh when you look at a
campaign like Massachusetts like that
that has to hurt when you are uh seeing
a campaign that drops 30 million dollars
and loses by uh 10 points uh that and I
think the reason for that one big reason
for that is people
saw that this wasn't the voting method
for them this was the voting method for
the establishment uh what Ray Troy's
voting does is it uh if you like uh new
voices well sure uh go ahead and if you
want to put them as first but those uh
are just going to get transferred over
to other candidates and your voice is
not going to get heard and you see this
explicitly like I mentioned Maine Maine
was ranked Choice voting's opportunity
to show itself
if if Frank Trace voting allowed you to
express your voice in a meaningful way
and actually get it heard Maine would
have shown that but ranked first food is
ignoring your voice
um otherwise like you
uh Frank Choice voting would have worked
uh for new voices you would have seen
more support for third parties uh in
Maine a state that's known for
independent voices
and uh uh and so when we're when we're
looking at this again we have to go back
and think what are the core components
that we need in a voting method we need
a voting method that gets us uh clear
winners we have real data right now in
St Louis
um uh we we had previously a a mayor who
one with a fraction of the vote uh and
vote splitting among the uh black
community uh it was so apparent after
proposition D passed by over 60 percent
that the former mayor wasn't going to
get away with that anymore uh she
decided not to run as an incumbent she
decided enough to run because she saw
the writing on the wall that the
people's voice was going to hurt was
going to be heard and it was heard uh
that that uh the candidate that previous
lost previously lost is now uh uh was
leading with over uh well over 50
percent in that first round going into
the runoff
so we have real world data and the
reason that we do polling alongside of
this is to see is to see whether the
actual Best winner was the one who won
we can't just look at a vote look at an
election and say oh well there there is
a result there our voting method uh
succeeded you have to take data
alongside that to see whether the winner
was a good winner and you don't know
that unless you collect data that's what
we do otherwise you're just uh
hypothesizing uh whether you're or
speculating whether your your voting
method worked you can't do that you
actually have to collect data to be able
to tell whether your voting method was
effective and that's what we do and so
we have a solution in front of us right
now that is easy to implement and it's
easy to understand you have a
drastically better alternative than
you've been told you don't have to wait
for permission uh they're not going to
give you permission anyway uh you have
to demand it so I ask that you join us
in our movement to spread approval
voting our democracy need to now thank
you
thank you I think that Andrew might have
some questions from the audience if not
I have a question of my own and then I
have a question that someone sent to me
earlier in the week
sure so do I ever have questions there
have been 112 questions submitted in the
chat below us holy guacamole there is no
way that I will be able to do those to
to get through all of them I I have
tried to identify a handful that had
common themes throughout
um but I'll let you go firstly so you
you said you had one on top of your head
or that you had yeah yeah I would love
to hear your thoughts as well yeah so my
question is for Andrew A couple of times
you were not Andrew I'm sorry Aaron and
Aaron a couple of times you've referred
to uh Maine showing that um you know the
third party candidates
that it you know that didn't really work
for them so can you walk us through why
Maine was a failure from your
perspective
yeah so so in in Maine neither the Green
Party candidate nor the libertarian
Party candidate
um got more than two percent uh and so
we have to ask ourselves like did they
actually have more support than two
percent uh and surely they did uh and
the reason that ranked Choice voting
fails to show that support is because it
just ignores if not ignores data uh so
you look at all the uh information that
people put down on their ballot uh so if
a candidate isn't eliminated into a
later round all the uh lower rankings
for those ballots never even
acknowledged by the voting method uh and
so that never is reflected at all in
terms of support for those third-party
candidates uh whereas with approval
voting it doesn't ignore any data it
uses all the information so if you have
a voice that you want to give approval
voting picks up on that because it
doesn't ignore anything and that works
out excellent only for third parties
Independence because their voice is
always heard
from the audience so we we have about 10
minutes left in what was scheduled I'm
all right with going a little bit over
with that if you are but not too full
much further
um so I I have one question targeted to
each of you respectively and then a
question for both of you to answer at
the end
um so Leo I'll start with you
um several audience members have
questioned just how well ranked Choice
voting has actually worked in Ireland or
Australia they've asked whether it's at
particularly popular there or whether it
has succeeded in developing strong third
parties one of them pointed out that
Australia has fewer independent or minor
party seats than than say Canada even
though they Canada still use first pass
to post so do you have a response to
that and then how important is the
traction of third parties as a criteria
in evaluating these systems compared to
other things
but look if you want third parties you
have to get rid of single interlection
I mean it's just as simple as that and
you know Aaron accuses me of conflating
RCV with STV which is the multi-winner
form of ranked Choice voting I see it as
a family of systems um you know we're
debating the single winter form of
ranked Choice voting
um you know but I think we have to
consider the whole whole whole whole
family of ranked Choice voting systems
and yet Ireland has three to five
parties roughly Ireland does use the
multi-winner form uh Australia uses the
single winner form for its house which
tends to have two parties uses the
multi-winner form for its Senate which
tends to have more parties Canada has a
high degree of federalism which allows
for multiple parties in a strong Quebec
block uh you know look if
you know if if you had
uh you know I mean Aaron's talking about
the green party in in um presidential
elections and in a year in which the
stakes were very high there was just not
a lot of attention on third parties and
you know I mean maybe the green party
you know would have pulled gotten four
percent instead of two percent I mean
this is this is kind of picking on the
edges uh
so you know yeah yeah
single winner ranked Choice voting is
not going to generate a ton of a ton of
support for third parties um but neither
is approval voting either uh you have to
move past the single winner format if
you want if you really want uh multiple
parties and you know I mean I'm honestly
confused when Aaron's talking about the
The Establishment supporting rank Choice
voting uh because if if you followed the
campaign at all in Maine he'd know that
the establishment there was incredibly
against ranked Choice voting and it took
two initiatives in order to get it
passed because the establishment tried
to to shut it down so that that part is
confusing to me to confess
um Aaron my next question for you you
can squeeze in a little response to that
if you want just because I I know we're
trying to allow Equitable response times
um the approval voting specific question
that I had was is there any Hazard
regarding the variance from person to
person and what approval means or the
different thresholds that some people
would Express that they approve of a
candidate in their positions whereas
ranked Choice voting kind of gets around
that because you're only expressing
relative preferences rather than an
absolute one so how much is that
ambiguity and what approval signifies a
problem to the accuracy of approval
voting's results
um
that that threshold for the individual
may vary
um but despite that uh when we're
looking at honest assessments uh as the
electorate as a whole uh we're still
seeing that strong winner getting
elected and ultimately uh that's what
matters uh I'm I'm a little uh put off
by uh these response about
um it not mattering about
uh being able to capture third parties
or independent support uh these are new
voices and and also uh we
but this is basically arguing for is
that we ignore people's voice and I
don't think that's just at all uh so
like when we look at the Democratic
primary for instance I pointed out that
Yang for instance uh under both ranked
Choice voting and priority voting was
getting under 10 are we saying that it's
okay for new voices to get marginalized
because that's what's happening under
priority voting and that's what's uh
continuing to happen under ranked Choice
voting uh whereas approval voting gives
those uh those candidate support so that
they can't be marginalized when they
bring in new voices I don't think this
kind of unfair marginalization is what
we wanted a voting method and again like
that's why we want approval voting
because we want to be able to pick up on
those voices
come on that's a bad faith argument
Aaron and you know it
um
you know that's a bad faith art so let's
look at look at the data I mean uh in
Maine uh
these other candidates are getting a
pittance of their support
I mean
look I mean if the green party had more
support we'd see it in we'd see it in
polls we don't need voting methods you
know and Andrew Yang I mean look Andrew
Yang has not been marginalized he's
running for mayor of New York City he
has a huge Yang gang uh you know he
wasn't going to win the Democratic
primary anyway but he got a ton of
attention and he really did Elevate some
new ideas
um you know I I have a hard time
understanding how those voices would
have been picked up in polls they use
plurality voting when you use a terrible
voting when you use a terrible
measurement instrument of course it's
not going to be picked up
run all the approval voting polls you
want I mean I I don't care I mean that
that doesn't matter I mean it's a
question but when people are actually
having to vote they have to vote
strategically uh so you know like I know
I mean I'm not trying to I want more
voices I'm the guy who's arguing for
multi-party democracy uh you know I but
I I mean I think we're brushing up here
we're brushing up against the limits of
the single winner system that if you you
really wanted more voices you should
join me in supporting proportional
representation I mean that's that's it
if that's what's really important to you
Aaron and maybe it is proportional
representation is going to bring in a
lot more new voices so will you join me
in that uh I'm I'm a supporter of a
proportional representation and if
that's what this debate was about I
would have talked about it more but this
debate is about addressing uh offices
that are inherently a single winner and
uh and it's important that for those
offices that we make sure that we get
strong people elected and that when
people have voices uh that are bringing
new ideas to the table that we don't
ignore them because that's what's
happening under priority voting that's
what's happening under ranked Choice
voting and we don't have to look at
hypotheticals anymore
you can't argue that people are going to
uh constantly use uh tactical strategies
in a way that nullifies the election
when we have first-hand knowledge of
actual elections when that's not coming
to fruition and as approval voting gets
implemented in more and more places
we're going to see even more and more
examples of that and it's going to be
harder to put put out those bad faith
arguments all right well I'm looking
forward to seeing approval voting
implemented in a place in with a with a
a single winner I mean I I I I find it
interesting that although we cite St
Louis actually St Louis has a runoff so
it's sort of like you know I mean RCV is
also called instant runoff voting if
approval voting works so well then why
not just have it elect the mayor
directly why do you need a a runoff
election
so the reason in St Louis that we use
our runoff is because in some cases
there are parameters about how a state
may interpret uh what a majority is uh
but I think it's important to recognize
the no voting method can guarantee a
majority uh by merely throwing out
candidates until there are two it's
really just contriving a majority so in
those cases we're doing it just to
satisfy a state's interpretation of of
majority and fortunately approval
learning is so flexible that it is able
to work with a lot of different
circumstances including the one in St
Louis but I I don't think anyone uh
would argue in good faith that a
traditional runoff system is not a
single winner uh method whether you're
using it with priority voting or if
you're using it with approval voting
but then why not just have it for the
the final result I mean anyway that's a
that's an academic argument
um I I am glad that the the discussion
has become almost as Lively as the
comments section beneath us
um there there is there is one more
question I think we have time for it
which is maybe a little bit blessed
where you might not necessarily disagree
um there's a lot of comments coming in
pointing out that there are many other
voting methods besides those even within
the single winner limitations besides
those we've endorsed today which is kind
of ironic given that escaping this Doom
group of only two options to choose from
is one of the things we're aiming to
achieve
um star voting you know for example or
ranking in some way so what I'll ask you
to close is
um using your voting method of choice
tell us what either your next favorite
method or methods are using like so Lee
you know what's your second favorite
voting method what's your third choice
and then Aaron of what other voting
methods do you approve as improvements
over of the status quo
well you know I mean when it comes to
single winter elections you know I would
say either either franchise voting or a
two-round election runoff election you
know when it comes to proportional
representation you know I think we
addition to STV we could consider open
list PR uh we can consider mixed member
proportional New Zealand German system
um you know but but I I feel like
there's this desire among you know
voting elections nerds and it's a fun
thing to do to come up with some new
voting system uh and you know but you
know the reality is is that we've been
you know this is this is not a new
debate it's 150 170 year old debate and
a lot of these voting methods have been
you know debated and tried and you know
there's a a reason why brand Choice
voting is one of the most you know is is
a very widely used method and all of
these other families of voting methods
are not used is because prank Choice
voting works pretty well
and that's as simple as that
in terms of other voting methods I would
say score voting is probably a strong
runner-up to approval voting with
approval voting uh you're looking at
really kind of uh rare isolated cases
where like approval voting would not get
the same winner as score voting
um maybe fewer than one in 100 or
something like that
but with approval voting you're getting
uh so much for so little in terms of
complexity costs and actual cost uh that
you're you're getting a real bargain
with approval voting it's
um and uh and like looking at the
comparing with the Alternatives now
um you're getting that you're getting
better performance in some of these
Alternatives uh that are being proposed
and you're doing it uh for not while not
having the complexity associated with it
and not having to have the the extra
experts is associated with it either
all right
um then on that note it is 445 which is
the advertised close of this event
um thank you all for coming both
participants and the the attendees we
will post the recording afterwards on
the El effective altruism social media
and among other places so you will be uh
able to continue the conversation uh
amongst yourselves and um thank you for
what I think has been a productive
Exchange
thank you thanks Andrew thanks Lee
thanks Aaron thank you bye-bye